having the assignments and in this
Workshop so this has been an amazing
experience for me so I've learned so
many things over the last few weeks and
I'm sure you know this this will
continue to be the case and so today I'm
going to talk about the testing
voluntary social distancing and this
spread of infection and this is a joint
work with Daron assamoglu also usdaqdar
and other ashmatican who is sitting uh
here in the audience
um so one thing you know I should I
should highlight is you know we sort of
thought about this work at the very
early uh sort of stages of the pandemic
and you know back then testing was one
of the main issues so you know with sort
of that mindset let me tell you you know
what this work is about
um so you know testing is one of the
most sort of effective ways for
controlling pandemic now I can list you
know many reasons uh for why that's the
case I mean for instance it uh helps you
know to identify uh infected people and
you know so that they can treat fastly
and it helps to again you know identify
uh and isolate you know infected people
and so that you know you prevent the
spread of the virus and it also you know
helps to identify people who came into
sort of close contact with uh you know
positive cases so that they can take the
um sort of necessary uh precautionary
you know actions and and this is going
to reduce the sort of asymptomatic you
know Transmissions
um and you know there's no doubt that
you know because of you know these
reasons uh many government agencies have
you know invested a lot in sort of
expanding the testing capacity
and you know obviously you know absent
the sort of strategic behavior of users
which you know hopefully I'm going to
clarify This this term throughout the
talk uh increasing testing is going to
sort of decrease the infection you know
in a society so it's going to make users
better off
so the sort of question we're going to
ask in this thought is you know is there
a downside to increasing testing
and the sort of logic that we have in
mind is you know by increasing testing
individuals are going to become sort of
less cautious you know they're going to
be more socially active and you know
this can potentially increase the sort
of the infection in the inner population
and potentially this can offset the
impact of increasing tests so this is
the sort of you know trade-off we're
going to explore in this talk yes when
you say testing do you mean large-scale
screening of the whole population or do
you mean like targeted testing about
symptoms yeah very good question no so
this is like a very simple I will talk
about the model so the question was you
know what do I mean by testing is it
like a targeted testing so it's not so
it will be you know I have a society and
then you know with some probability I'm
going to test you know each one of the
individuals in that Society you know in
a homogeneous way so I'm not doing you
know any targeted testing or you know
any uh any you know contact tracing or
anything like that so this is a like a
very simple you know theoretical
modeling framework and you know by
testing thing I mean you know you
allocate this this many tests to this to
this you know community so with this
probability you're going to test each
one of these people well then I would
agree with you that it's shown to be
effective
if you do large scale screening you have
to screen
huge amount of people very frequently to
have any effect
yes I see your point so so what we're
going to see is you know from this point
of view that you know by increasing
testing people are going to be more
socially active so from that perspective
it's going to hurt as well but you know
you write that you know if I have this
amount of tests there may be better ways
you know for you know sort of targeting
these these steps to individuals and
Society completely agree with that yes
their level of social activities
so the question was you know why because
so the question is why people are going
to increase their social activity level
and so this is going to be you know
clear once I introduce the model uh but
you know as a sort of a precursor effect
when you know there are more tests out
there you're still sort of more
comfortable to you know go out you know
it just increase your social activity
because uh you're just more confident
that you know if there are possible
cases out there you know with a higher
program they're just going to be caught
so you just you know increase your
social activity so that's the sort of
Watch
so and you also assume if someone is
detected as positive they'll behave the
right way yes exactly so yes so once yes
again so once I introduce the model it's
going to be become clear but you know
once you test positive you're going to
be isolated yes so you're not going to
spread infection anymore yes
which you know may not necessarily be
the case but you know again this is more
like a modeling framework and you know
that's an assumption we're going to make
and you know besides testing you know
another instrument you know to control
pandemic is you know social distancing
and uh you know there are evidence that
you know animals do that to some extent
so there may be some evolutionary
reasons for doing that so the other
question we're going to sort of explore
in this talk is you know how should
testing be combined with social
distancing so that's sort of the second
question we're going to explore
so with that with that in mind so let me
tell you you know the plan for this
start so we're going to develop a game
theoretic model and to study these
issues so this is again uh more like a
modeling framework so there is no no
data
um
and you know we're going to model social
activity
um and you know voluntary social
distancing as a network formation game
so this is going to be a network
formation game so what do I mean by that
so individuals are going to decide about
their social activity levels
which is going to sort of determine the
contact Network an underlying sort of
social network over which the infection
is going to express
and then you know how do we you know
sort of think about the spread of the
infection so I'm going to use a sort of
a very simple discrete time process to
sort of model the spread of the
infection so I'm not going to use you
know sir type of models and this is I
mean this choice is mainly for for
tractability
you know hopefully this this point will
become more clear throughout the time so
what does testing do in this in this
framework
so testing is going to enable uh
you know isolation of the of the
infected individuals you know once they
test someone then I'm going to assume
that I'm going to end up in isolating
that person so you know there is no
infection uh you know spreading from
that that you know infected person
um and then what do we show with with
this framework so I'm going to
characterize the uh equilibrium of this
game which is basically the activity
level of of individuals for any sort of
given testing policy
um and then how much do how much do
people
how much do your participants know about
the state of the world do they know the
global level of infection do they know
their probability do they know which of
their friends are infected who got
tested or so what information do is
player in this game have so this is
going to be like a full information game
so I know the activity level of other
people so I know you know people are
going out with this rate so I know if
you're going out I know it for every one
of my neighbors correct
um and then you know like the testing
probability that is out there as well
and I know that you got tested yes you
know iPad tested as well yes that's
right but I don't see you sneezing so I
don't know whether you're sick uh well
so that's not going to be important
because you know you're going to make
that decision before so you know it's
you know in the morning you're going to
wake up you're going to decide whether
you're going to go shopping or not you
know at that point you know whether the
person you're going to interact with is
going to be or not it's not going to
matter so you know you sort of extend to
decide whether you want to go out or not
and then once we sort of characterize
the equity you know we're going to look
at the optimal testing policy
um and then sort of characterize the
impact of the testing policy and the
equilibrium amount yes please
is there a pre-existing social network
prior to this contact Network very good
no so you know it's just like you have a
bunch of nodes there's no social network
but you know once people decide about
their social activity there will be some
realized you know social network over
which you know the infection is gonna
spread
all right so I'm going to you know make
the model more more precise and in the
next slide so in terms of the main
results and insights uh so we sort of
have three main insights so the first
one is you know greater testing can lead
to more sort of social activity or in a
less social distancing and therefore a
denser social network
and then what I show is you know for a
range of parameters you know
paradoxically greater testing can
increase infection you know you you know
expect once you increase testing you
know it's going to decrease the
infection probability we'll see that for
a range of parameters that's that's not
necessarily the case
and then this sort of non-monotonicity
result it has you know some implications
in terms of the optimal testing poles so
the first thing is you know the optimal
testing policy may leave some of the
testing capacity of the society unused
you know you have this many tests but
you know you somehow find it optimal to
not use all of those
yeah this may sound strange but you know
what this implies or what this suggests
is you know testing should be combined
with mandatory social distancing and you
know once you do that then you know
you're going to end up using all the
testing capacity and things are going to
become you know much more much more
efficient
any question about you know the high
level uh idea
okay
the tests are able to detect those who
are asymptomatic or the tests only
detect those because viral nodes again
so this is like a sort of a
the way we're going to model it is at a
sort of a more abstract level that you
know that's not going to matter that
much so the tests are just going to uh
you know sort of determine the
probability with which you're gonna uh
you know be tested once you are infected
so that's there so once I you know
introduce the model it's going to become
more clear but you know whether you're
asymptomatic or not it's not going to
matter that much so I'm not going to
model that in in our framework you know
I'm not going to model you know
asymptomatic you know transmission or or
you know but that I think he wanted to
ask whether the tests are perfect or not
but all right very good very good uh
I'm not going to assume they're perfect
but you know it's not going to matter
for the results that I will present so
I'm going to assume that you know if you
are
infected and not tested you're going to
transmit infection with some probability
and if you are infected and and and
tested you still are going to trust me
it with some probability you know
because before uh you know you test
positive you may have interacted with
people but this probability is smaller
than uh you know the case that that
you're not testing so it's just you know
if you're tested you're still in a
transmit but with a smaller probability
so this can be zero or you know anything
is more only four but it's not that
everybody will transmit either translate
if I got
good so yeah this is General ideas that
everyone just wakes up
no that's not the case so I guess I
guess that's so let me actually answer
that that question once I introduce sort
of the uh the stochastic process
governing the the sort of spread of the
infection so I guess you know I can
answer that that question it once I
introduce that yeah
yeah
all right and in terms of the literature
we sort of relate to to the three
branches of the literature so one is on
endogenous social network formation so
here we're going to use a sort of a
simple Network formation model in which
in the probability of two individuals
connecting with each other is just going
to be proportional to the product of
their social activities so that's the
that's the sort of a network formation
model with routines and we also relate
to the sort of literature in econ that
sort of explores uh that you know
precautionary tools sometimes can
increase risk taking and can have you
know adverse effects and this has been
documented in the context of you know
hydraulic brakes and also in the context
of HIV treatments
and the third sort of branch of
literature that we relate to is the
recent literature on epidemics and
covid-19 and so pretty much all the
talks in this Workshop should have been
listed there so I did list a few of
those and you know didn't have enough
space you know to include the rest uh
but you know the list of papers we see
here is by no means
and you know as as you see you know all
of those are after 20 so that's
all right so let me jump to the model
so I'm going to consider an individual's
1 to n
and then each individual yeah if I
consider an individual eye for instance
is going to decide about her level of
social activity so this is going to be
some number x i between 0 and 1. and
this is going to be probability with
which you know you're willing to connect
with others
and then there are going to be K agent
types with different values for social
activity you know for instance you know
young people may have you know a higher
value for you know interacting with
others you know compared with other
um so there will be K agent types with
different values for social activity but
for the most of the thought I'm just
going to assume there are two types
low value and high value agents and you
know I will show you how the results you
know are going to extend uh when we
consider you know more than two types so
again I'm going to consider you know two
type of two types of Agents you know
high value and low value in addition to
the excise yes so this is the value per
social activity level so at the end of
the day you know once I introduce the
utility is going to be clear so your
sort of utility from social activity is
just going to be your value times your
actual social activity level so it's
going to be your VI times you know your
x i
thank you
all right so you know just a little bit
of the notation so I'm going to denote
the setup high and low value agents by
Cal H and Cal head
um and then you know in terms of the the
spread of the infection so the virus
infection uniformly random you know
individual
um
and then spreads according to sort of a
variation of the independent Cascade
model so I'm going to you know make that
more formal
um but you know before that so let me
tell you about the testing policy and
also the contact Network so what is a
testing policy in our setting so we're
going to consider like a very simple
testing policy so the testing policy is
just a pair of you know two
probabilities Alpha L and Alpha H and
those are going to be the probability
with which you test you know low value
agents and the probability with which
you test you know high value agents so
that's you know what I mean by by
testing poles
I'm assuming you know that so I'm
assuming you do have that information so
it's uh you know you can say you know
based on age of people you know I'm
going to decide whether they're low
value or higher value but you know this
is a full information game so I'm going
to assume that you know that
all right
so you know let me tell you about the
contact Network and then you know based
on this contact Network I can introduce
the uh the sort of the the infection
probability and the the sarcastic
process for that so what is a contact
Network here so the social activity
profile you know this Vector of X1 to xn
this is going to generate a contact
Network
the random contact Network so what's the
probability of you know agent I and J
being connected with each other that's
just going to be proportional some Ada
some number between 0 and 1 times the
social activity of of individual I times
the social activity of individual J
so that's how we Define you know the the
contact Network and it depends on the uh
so if the social activity of the two
endpoints
you can see that x i Jace
as a player in the game do I see only
the X eyes or do I also see the realized
edges you see the X eyes you see the X
ice
and then because you're you know making
a decision example you know that's the
only thing that will appear in your
expected utility
so you don't need to sort of see the the
realization you make this decision
before seeing the realization and you
try to work with your sort of expected
utility I think the way you're modeling
preferences your value for social
activities independent of how many
people are participating in the social
activity right
yes that's a good point yes so it's not
so it's like you know how often I'm
gonna go out and you know once I do that
I'm going to interact with others yes
that's a good one so it's not a sort of
a
pairwise you know stable kind of you
know model of of net for formation just
like you know I'm deciding you know this
is how often I want to go out and that's
it so I'm I get value for that and you
know one thing you know regarding to
that you know let's take you to think
about you know what sort of activities
you know I'm capturing with this sort of
model uh you know one is you know it
doesn't require sort of a bilateral uh
agreement so you know if I go out you
know I'm going to get social activity
and the other is you know this captures
activities in which
you know multiple individuals are going
to interact with each other you know for
instance you know you want to play
basketball
no you guess you can play basketball
solo but it's not going to be that fun
but you know you need more than one
person you know to to play basketball
basketball or you want to go to office
you know you're going to uh you know see
people you're going to a restaurant or
you know you're going shopping so it
captures this sort of things and it
doesn't capture you know activities like
solo activities you know it doesn't
capture you going for biking or hiking I
would have thought the other way around
I would have thought that it uh captures
you know uh solo activities like hiking
but then you know I randomly bump into
somebody and they give me covered but uh
you know if it's if I'm thinking about
going to a party I would enjoy that
party more if more other people were
also so I guess I guess we both know
what this capture but yes so if you're
thinking you know if I go hiking you
know I get to interact with others sure
then that is going to be captured in
this model as well uh but you know
essentially this is going to capture uh
you know scenarios in which you get to
interact with people you know you're
going out and you know by doing that you
sort of interact with people you see
them with
anybody
sitting in the ranches Imagining the
other people which is
[Music]
that
so you know I'm assuming you go to
restaurant to eat so you know that's
that's your end goal so it's like you
know you get value you get that you know
you get value from going to restaurant
so that's your value for social activity
but by doing that if others also go to
that restaurant you know you're going to
get in contact with them so that's how
you think about it you know if I go
shopping you know you know I get some
value for that you know how often I want
to go shopping
so I did that to that exactly so the
value is you want food you know you want
to get restaurant to eat so you get
value from that but you know by doing
that you sort of interact with others or
you know you tend into close contact
with others and you may get infection
from this yes
and that's going to sort of simplify the
analysis you know I I will show you how
this is going to help us
um any
any requests
very good so now that we know the sort
of contact Network the or the social
network over which the infection is
going to spread so let's say you know
what is the sort of the stochastic
process governing this spread of the
infection
so one of the individuals again
uniformly at random is going to get
infected and the infection spreads to
others you know over this this contact
Network by using a sort of a slight
variation or extension of the
independent Cascade model of temper
charge and and John climber so let me
tell you what is that so again you know
we have a source
chosen you know uniformly at random
and then an infected and not tested
individuals you know and therefore you
know not isolated
he's going to
you know be active for one round and
it's going to transmit infection to her
neighbors with some you know
transmission probability beta some
number between 0 and 1.
versus here you know node one if is not
uh you know test that is going to
transmit to 2J and an i as well with
some probability beta
and and infected and tested individual
is going to you know be isolated so here
I can assume that you know the
transmission probability is just going
to be zero but you know to allow for you
know more flexibility what I'm going to
assume is you know before the isolation
takes place that this individual is
going to be active and you know we
sort of a smaller probability this
individual may you know infect her
neighbors so you know if here node one
is infected and tested
you know she's still going to infect the
neighbors but with the smaller
probabilities
[Music]
yes
or not I will still go to the I will
still get my full value of going
Supermarket exactly so you know today in
the morning you're going to wake up and
you're going to say well today I want to
go you know for lunch to this restaurant
and for dinner to this other restaurant
so there you decide your exam and then
at the end of the day you know at night
you may you know have gotten the
infection no that's that's how we should
think about it
all right
and you know an active individual is
going to remain active for for one round
so we're going to end up having you know
a bunch of active individuals I'm sorry
I still want to understand so when you
so this morning I go out and get but
maybe I have uh
I might want to avoid being tested
because if I'm tested I might get be
then you will actually have some chance
that tomorrow you isolate me in fact
tomorrow I can't go to the supermarket
so I really don't want to be tested
because I want to go to the supermarket
maybe infected or not that's that's an
excellent point so you know we'll see
that you know the sort of the negative
term in your utility is just going to be
the probability of infection and that
can include you know what you're saying
to some extent but to sort of exactly
capture what you're saying we needed
sort of a dynamic model and this is not
a dynamic model so here you know example
I'm going to decide about my social
activity level and and you know get some
utility from there but you know what
you're saying you know requires more of
a dynamic model and then you want to see
you know whether people you know have
incentives to perhaps misreport that you
know they've been infected or things
like that so I'm not going to consider
any of those so this is a sort of a much
simpler model
sorry
exactly or you know how often yes this x
i your you know social activity level
that's your only choice yes
right and you know we're going to end up
having a bunch of active agents and the
infection simultaneously and
independently from active agents is
going to transmit to each of the uh sort
of uninfected uh nodes in an order
independent fashion so for instance here
if one and two are infected then the
probability of infection getting to know
J is going to be 1 minus 1 minus beta
squared so if one of these people I mean
for instance 2 is tested then this
probability is just going to be smaller
one minus one minus beta times 1 minus
beta
so this is the stochastic process that
you know defines the spread of the
infection so now with that I can
introduce this notation so this is like
an important notation that I will use
you know throughout the talk so P sub I
superscript if x this is the so the
vector of social activity levels this is
also a function of the testing policy
Alpha L and Alpha H and this is going to
be the expected infection probability of
individual I in the random network of
contacts for social activity level X and
for testing policy Alpha L and Alpha h
any question about this quantity
so this is a like a complicated quantity
you know it's not easy to sort of write
this down explicitly but we'll see that
you know the only thing we really need
is some uh sort of properties of of this
this quantity uh the that's you know
pretty much the only thing we need for
the analysis which you know hopefully
will become clear you know throughout
the talk
all right and so let me tell you about
the utility of Agents I guess you know I
sort of uh talked about that a little
bit uh so if I look at you know agent I
your utility is going to have like a
positive term
that's going to be VI value the per
social activity level times her social
activity level X I and you know this
value remember here we're considering
only two types so this value is either
high value or low value so that's a
positive term in the in the initiative
this is because you know individuals
values social interaction
and then there will be like a negative
term this is just going to be the
probability of infection
and this is you know simply because
individuals incurate costs when when
they get infected then I have a third
term so this is
you know I could just not have that but
I guess it just makes sense to have it
so this is like a positively small cost
of you know getting tested or you know
the expected cost of getting tested so
what this third term says is you know
everything else equal you know I prefer
not to be tested you know these swaps
for instance for covet they're they're
kind of painful so everything else equal
you prefer not to be tested
questions
results be tested yes everything else
equal make sure what your situation is
exactly like everything else equals if
there is no externality whatsoever then
you just don't want to you know use the
swap so that's that's what what it says
and you know you can imagine this thing
being small so you know it has no sort
of impact yes um is it easy to extend
the like additional types for having
different um risk adverseness in terms
of getting affected or not it's a good
point like uh
having sort of a idiosyncratic sort of
coefficient here perhaps is that with
yes that is easy so the only thing that
will be important is the sort of
relative way that you know you assign to
your social activity level and and to
infection probability uh so it's it's
sort of you know one can you know think
about you know people uh may have
different costs you know from getting
infection which is is the case
um so uh even for the low value
individuals v i is positive right so yes
wouldn't they still want High activity
even
but then that still increase their
utility so if they they increase their
social activity yes it's going to
increase their value from that but you
know per social activity they just have
a lower you know value for for you know
for uh increasing their their social
activities so it's like
you know this VI think about it as the
units of social activities this is a
parasocial activity and this XI is your
actual social activity which is your
choice but this VI is you know something
you know inherent you know uh yeah so
it's just you know uh you just enjoy
staying at home more than someone else
you know it's just you know this is that
sort of parameters
there's no cost to like if I don't like
social activity I don't have a cost I
see so you want to have a negative no
I'm not going to consider that in this
model that's it
sort of discourage you know social
interaction so we're not gonna
that you could introducing your utility
also things that depends on global uh
level of infection
because for instance you can care about
transmitting the disease which does not
appear on your utility function
so so here everything is a agent uh
centered but could you have something
that is more population centered as well
oh very good point yes I guess this goes
back to like the question that kimon
asked earlier so the externality is here
so here your infection probability the
infection probability of individual eye
this depends on the activity level of
others so if others are more socially
active so this is going to be higher so
you know I I incur some cost there so it
is there so the externality does exist
in this model but it's only in this you
know probability of infection term and
not in the in the first step
so it may be hard to sort of see it but
you know this Vector it depends on the
sort of the activity level of others so
there is some externality here
I think he
so
I think it's a question right okay I
understood the question differently
there's two possible pis one is my
probability of getting infection again
infected if some random other person
starts infection
but maybe I'm a very socially conscious
person and I don't want to be patient
one in a global infection so I might
care about the probability of creating
an epidemic that's a good point so sort
of having the infection probability of
other people perhaps you know with a
smaller coefficient so I'm not going to
consider that so whether that changes
things or not I actually don't know so
it may or may not so I don't know so
that's something we can with your model
the two may be the same
uh it's it's white well the probability
rights of
since you have this independent Cascade
model the probability of being in fact
it's the probability of happening to lie
in the
largest cluster more or less
and the probability of infecting us is
also the probability of lying in the
largest cluster so maybe they're
actually yeah I guess related here or
yes so there may be some connection yes
of course yes so you know my probability
of infection is of course related to
others probability of infection uh
so again I don't know what happens if
you include the infection probability of
others in the utility as well so you're
saying it doesn't matter because
I don't know what you call an infection
is that if a random person gets infected
or if it's conditioned on being a large
outbreak then of getting infected I
don't quite know what so this is the
probability of Ever Getting infection in
the independent casket model
under the assumption set of random
person this patient one exactly
initially like a uniformly random agent
is going to get infected and your number
I you know your agent I probability of
you ever getting infected and I think in
your model the probability of me
infecting a random person is exactly the
same as a random person affecting me
because it's just the probabilities that
they're connected in your percolation
model
yes so actually your social good is
exactly the same as egoistic one here
yeah it yeah I guess I don't know the
answer but you know I I trust you know
christianso I guess the answer is you
know it's yes it's not gonna matter I
guess uh yes perfect
all right so you know before telling you
about the equilibrium characterization
and and the analysis you know I told you
you know there are a few properties of
this infection probability that is
pretty much you know all that matters in
the analysis so let me tell you a little
bit about those properties
so the first one is monotonicity in
action profile so that simply says you
know higher social activity means a
higher infection probability so that's
the sort of the first property that you
know this quantity has and you know we
are going to require
so the second one is concavity in action
profile so what that says is you know if
I'm agent I my infection probability is
going to be concave in my in the social
activity level or you know in other
words the marginal increasing the
infection probability is going to
decrease as the the social activity
increases
so you know that's something we prove
holds for our you know process and and
it you know kind of makes sense to sort
of expect that thing
the third property is monotonicity in
testing probability
so all that says is you know simply as a
increased testing probabilities the
infection probability is going to
decrease you know something that we
would you know naturally expect and my
claim is you know these three properties
are the main properties that you know
I'm going to use in the analysis so if
you don't like you know the stochastic
process I you know introduce here as
long as you know whatever probability of
infection you have satisfies these three
properties then the rest of the analysis
is going to go through
all right so let me actually highlight
this sort of last bullet here
monotonicity in testing probability so
what that says is you know for the same
action profile if I test more the
infection probability is going to
decrease
so let me you know write that here for
an exogenous social activity profile
increasing the testing probability
decreases the infection probability
now the sort of question we're going
after is you know how about in
equilibrium when individuals choose
their social activity endogenesis so can
we can we have the same thing or you
know uh something else can happen there
but you know in order to answer this
question we do need to characterize the
equilibrium right so we do need to
characterize the equilibrium social
activity of Ages so let's let's actually
work toward that
so in terms of the solution Concepts I'm
going to consider symmetric equilibrium
where the action of each agent depends
on you know her position in the network
her type uh but not on her index and
this is you know something that is going
to simplify the analysis and in the
paper we do consider you know asymmetric
equilibrium as well the results are you
know very similar
sorry there's a question
yes thank you just just understand if
you only had one type of Agents when you
get the same
answer right where we only have one
action we symmetic equilibrium correct
so yes so this sort of non-monotonicity
that I was you know talking about you
still get it with one type but you know
I think you know the results for two
types is just more interesting so that's
why I chose you know two types so you
can have the sort of the
non-monetization for any integer K and I
chose you know two that's the bare
minimum yes but K is the bare minimum
that makes things more interesting yeah
but uh yes your your intuition is
definitely right that you know with K1
with one type you sort of get the same
non-monetronicity results that is true
all right and then you know if I look at
the utility of each agent that's going
to be convex in her social activity
level because you know it has a linear
term minus a concave term so what that
implies is you know the equilibrium
is going to be you know either 0 1 or a
mix between these two
so we should look at you know equilibria
that you know belong to that class well
let's just start with the simplest one
so I'm going to ask when is social
activity one for both high value and low
value agents and equilibrium in this
game so let's see you know whether we
can answer this question I'm trying to
answer this question you know I'm simply
going to evaluate the utility of Agents
when you're playing one and you know the
utility of Agents when you know they're
playing one and one of them you know
deviates to zero
so the left hand side you know if I'm
agent I if I'm playing one I'm Gonna Get
You Know value VI
and I'm gonna get this you know
probability of infection so this is high
value agents are playing one low value
agents are playing one and the testing
policy is Alpha L and Alpha h
if I deviate as agents I and and place 0
so what's going to be you know my
utility so you're not going to get any
value from social interactions and
because you know my X I essentially is
zero I'm I'm isolated in this network so
the only chance you know for me to get
to get the infection is you know when
I'm the source of the infection so the
probability of getting infected is just
going to be one over it
how do you know that equivalent exists
if it's zero one it could be I'm playing
zero then you want to play one then I
will want to play Zero so so far you
only have argued to me that I is at my
best response is zero or one not that
this is an equilibrium right so this is
going to sort of show that you know this
if this thing holds for all I then this
is going to be equilibrium but I guess
your question is deeper is like what if
there are other equilibrium as well yeah
that's a that's a possibility and you
know what I will argue well I'm not
gonna you know have it on the slides but
you know in the paper we show that you
know these are the sort of unique
equilibrium you will end up having so
you know I'm going to characterize the
unique equilibrium here so you you're
not worried about you know other you
know perhaps non-intuitive equilibrium
existing as well
all right you know as you said you know
if this thing holds for all I and here
because we have two types only if this
thing holds for you know a low type
agent and a high uh type agent then you
know we can say for this region for
Alpha L and Alpha H for testing policy
belonging to this set A1
the sort of social activity of o1 you
know both agents being fully active
that's going to be unequality so that's
easy to see
see you know what happens if I
sort of decrease this testing
probability or you know this testing
policy
so if I decrease the testing policy
these Alpha L and Alpha h
this probability of infection is going
to increase and at some point I will end
up violating this constraint
so I will you know step outside of this
set
so which one is going to you know be
violated first I mean it's easy to see
that the constraint corresponding to low
value agents is going to be violated
first
and then one can argue that there is no
symmetric pure equilibrium there no
going back to Christian questions so one
can argue that there is no symmetric
pure equilibrium there you know one
needs to look at uh you know mixed
strategy equally
so now let's let's look at that so
what's a sort of a candidate for a mixed
strategy equilibrium so let's consider
this symmetric equilibrium the low value
agents are going to play mixed and the
high value agents are going to play
fully active are going to play one so
let's see when we can have you know such
equilibrium
my claim is you know in this other set
A2 which is you know disjoint from the
previous set we're going to have such
equilibrium so let's look at you know
this first constraint here so what does
it say so this is essentially the
constraint we had you know in the other
set A1 but with the opposite direction
so this is the constraint that that is
violated
and if I look at the second inequality
here so what this says is the infection
probability of a low type agent when
others you know other high values are
playing one I as a low value agent I'm
playing one as well and the rest of the
low value agents are playing zero so
this infection probability
is less than VL plus one awareness so
it's the opposite direction of this so
those are the constraints I need you
know in terms of the infection
probability of a low value agent then
there is another constraint for the
infection probability of high value and
I'm saying you know with these
constraints or you know in this set A2
there exists a mixed strategy
equilibrium and that's going to be
unique so let's see whether we can we
can prove that
so you know how can I argue that there
exists uh sort of a mixed strategy
equilibrium for low value agents so all
I need to do is to
look at their utility when they're
playing one and others are playing mixed
in their utility when they're you know
playing zero and others are playing next
and equate these two
so if I'm a low value agent and I'm
playing one this is my value
this is my infection probability high
value agents are playing one I'm playing
one as a low value agent in the rest of
the low value agents are playing a mixed
strategy with this gamma L with
probability gamma L they're playing one
with probability of one minus gamma L
they're playing zero and this gamma L
and it's a function of of the testing
pulse
and if I play Zero then you know we have
already argued that my utility is going
to be minus one over n and to show that
you know an equilibrium exists here all
I need to do is to sort of prove that
there is a fixed point you know for this
for this equation here there exists this
gamma L here so how can we see that so
my claim is you know the fact that this
gamma exists it just Falls from these
two inequalities and you know mean value
theorem and the certain monotonicity of
the infection probability in the social
activity levels
so what did you just pull so we proved
that that you know in this other set A2
there exists a sort of equilibrium in
which high value agents are going to
play one and low value agents are going
to play a mixed strategy what's the
probability of mixing it's this gamma L
that we see you know solution of this
fixed Point equation yes foreign
just
continuous game right yes so you can see
that there there is no sort of pure
equilibrium in this set so you know I
guess actually I can I can answer your
question in the next slide so if that's
fine so one thing before that so I just
want to highlight you know this
infection probability it's a complicated
object and you know finding this fixed
point is also you know you know
complicated or you know characterizing
this gamma L function is complicated but
the good thing is we only need you know
the fact that it exists and later I will
show a sort of a monotonicity result for
that as well and you know that's the
only thing we're going to need and
you're going back to to elon's question
so let me tell you the full
characterization and then hopefully you
know that's that's going to answer your
question as well so there exists you
know functions gamma L and Gamma H in
four regions and the reason we have four
is because you know we have two types so
if you had k-tops you know we would end
up having 2K regions
such that here is the equilibrium action
so here on the y-axis I have Alpha H
probability of testing high value agents
and the y-axis Alpha L probability of
testing low value agents and I'm going
to you know tell you what is the
equilibrium action of high value and low
value agents so if I'm in this region A1
then full activity for both agents for
high and low one one that's going to be
the sort of a unique equilibrium there
if I go to this set A2 we can prove that
there exists no pure strategy Equity we
are there so one needs to look at you
know you know uh sort of mixer strategy
equity
um and what is the mixed strategy
equilibria you know high value agents
are going to play one and low value
agents are going to you know mix with
this probability gamma l
ol I just have an understanding question
you have an X which you choose between 0
and 1.
is there a difference between playing
one with probability p and Zero versus
probability one minus P or playing
strategy P
because yes yes there is a difference
yes so and you really mean mixed here
right so because I could yes that's a
good point so you know you remember that
I told you that the utility of each
agent is is convex and therefore you
know your best response belongs to one
of the extremes so you know it's either
zero or one or a mix between those two
and you know interesting different from
the value in the middle which is
actually definitely worse very good yes
yes it's different than you know playing
something intermediate
part and you know as I keep sort of
decreasing the infection probability or
sorry like the testing probability and I
will get to this region A3 in that
region the equilibrium or the unique you
know equilibrium is going to be high
value agents plane one and low value
agents playing zero and if I you know
keep decreasing the the testing
probability I will get to a region in
which you know high value agents are
playing mixed with you know some other
function gamma H and low value agents
are going to play play Zero I think
that's the sort of the characterization
of the equilibrium
all right so now you know let's actually
policy on the infection probability
so I'm going to start with the with the
simplest case and in this region A1 so
in this region A1 full activity level
for you know both agent types is going
to be an equilibrium
so now if I increase the testing
probability
the infection probability is going to
it's going to decrease right so if I'm
within this region the action profile is
just you know fully active for both
types if I increase testing infection
probability is going going down you know
nothing surprising happens there
now let's look at what happens in region
two
so in this region 2 the infection
probability of low value agents the one
can use this you know fixed Point
equation to show that it's going to be
proportional to this gamma L function
that you know I introduce earlier
so again the infection probability of
low value agents in this region A2 is
going to be proportional to this gamma L
function which is you know the solution
of this fixed Point equation that we saw
in
my thing is
you know this gamma L function and
therefore the infection probability of
low value agents
is going to be increasing in the testing
probability and that's the sort of the
paradoxical result that you know I was
going after
you know this gamma L function and
therefore the infection probability of
low value agents is going to be
increasing you know in the testing
probability
so let's say you know how we can prove
this I have a we have two line proof of
this or four line proof of this and so
how can we say this so let's suppose the
contrary you know Alpha Prime is higher
than Alpha and Gamma L and Alpha Prime
is a small
so I'm going to get to a contradiction
so this is the cat you know these these
you know equations
really right it's always count the top
line as well
um all right so the first equation so
where does that come from so that's just
the definition of gamma l so it's just
this you know fixed Point equation right
so I have Alpha as a testing policy
gamma L and Alpha so it's just the
definition of this fixed mode
now let's look at the first inequality
so where does that come from so gamma L
Prime is a smaller so I'm sort of
decreasing the social activity level so
the infection probability is going to
decrease
so now let's look at this this other
inequality here so where does that come
from so I'm keeping the social activity
levels the same but you know I'm
increasing testing probabilities so
again the monotonicity of the infection
probability in the in the testing policy
in the testing probability this is going
to decrease right and the last equality
is again the definition of gamma L this
time evaluated at Alpha Prime you know
this is just a fixed Point equation that
we had and this is already a
contradiction showing that you know the
infection probability of low value
agents in this region you know as a you
know increase testing the infection
probability is going to go up
surprisingly
and you know one can argue you know the
same thing for you know Region Three and
and region four so let me you know put
all of this together so higher testing
in in the first region A1 it's going to
decrease the infection probability for
both types so nothing surprising happens
there
in region two higher testing is going to
increase the infection probability of
low value agents and it's going to have
no impact on the infection probability
of high value agents you know something
you know paradoxically happens there
again in the third region by increasing
testing the infection probability
decreases so nothing surprising there
but again in region four
increasing the testing probability is
going to sort of increase the infection
probability of high value agents
so so if the takeaway message here is
you know greater testing increases the
infection probability in regions A2 and
A4 that we have sort of mixed strategy
Equity so whenever we have that then by
increasing testing we're going to you
know end up increasing the the infection
probability
all right so let me illustrate this
result you know in in this picture
um so I'm going to look at this region
A4 so let's see you know if we can get
some intuition to this sort of
non-monetized civilism so what happens
in this region for so low value agents
are going to play Zero so the infection
probability is you know essentially zero
or you know one over n
high value agents this is going to be
their sort of infection probability high
value agents are playing mixed but then
as I increase the testing probability as
I increase Alpha here in this picture
I'm creating you know some incentive for
those people to go to full activity you
know I mean increasing testing you know
I'm creating some incentive for those
people to go to full activity
but you know one thing that we argued is
you know there is no pure strategy
equilibrium in this region you know
while I'm still in this region there is
no pure strategy equity
so what happens is you know in
equilibrium the incentives for mixing is
restored by by increasing the infection
probability so that's the sort of the uh
the intuition to keep in mind and then
you know as I further sort of increase
the testing probability uh you know high
value agents are going to start playing
full activity the infection probability
decreases there nothing surprising there
but you know if I further increase that
now low value agents start playing
um sort of mixed strategy and by
increasing the testing probability I'm
going to increase the uh the infection
probability of low value agents so again
you know something uh you know sort of
paradoxically happens there as well any
question about this
yes
this will be a naive question because I
don't really speak econ but this slide
helped me a lot so I guess the intuition
behind why this paradoxical Behavior
arises is it correct to say that as
testing increases because like you have
full information and you kind of know
the overall environmental risk is
dropping it incentivizes you more right
so yes that is right yes yes and does
that like if you had more of a myopic
strategy do you expect something would
similarly happen well is this really
from the Global Information no this is
coming from this yes so this is so to
see this sort of non-monet system you do
need to sort of have people who are
strategically you know deciding about
their social activities so you do need
that sort of behavior to to get this
sort of results and that's that's a good
point yes
right so
so I did characterize the equilibrium
for k equal to two times so I have a
picture to tell you what happens with uh
three types but you know I guess I don't
have enough time to go over that but you
know just to tell you you know what
happens in general for J types we can
you know still characterize the
equilibrium instead of having four
region we're going to have 2K region and
we still get this sort of non-monitoring
non-monotonicity result whenever we have
a mixed strategy equitable
all right so I would be happy to to talk
about this you know and offline
all right so so far we have argued that
increasing the testing capacity may
increase the infection probability of
individuals uh when we consider the
Strategic social distancing Behavior
now the next sort of natural question is
you know what are the implications of
this non-monotonistic result for the
optimal testing policy so let's let's
try to you know answer this question
what do I mean by Optimal testing policy
so I'm going to assume that there is a
sort of a limited testing capacity so
you know there are Theta and tests that
they can allocate to to this population
I'm going to sort of refer to this beta
as the testing capacity and I want to
see you know what would be the optimal
choice of alpha L and Alpha h
so here's a constraint that I need to
respect you know Alpha H probability of
testing high value agents Alpha L
probability of testing low value agents
the sum of these two it has to be less
than Theta so that's the constraint I'm
going to have you know when I'm deciding
about the the optimal testing policy
so what's the objective so the objective
is going to be social welfare it's going
to be the sum of the utilities of all
agents and you know I'm simply going to
maximize this
and you know there's a game here so
there's a sort of a Twist stage stack of
a game going on here so the social
planner is going to choose the testing
policy and given the testing policy the
unique symmetric equilibrium will be
played so this you know social activity
levels are the choices of the
individuals in equilibrium so you know
there's a sort of a two-stage game going
on
and the social planners problem is going
to be you know maximizing over the
testing policy the social welfare
subject to these two constraints
well many people did
you couldn't care about the epidemic
very good so I'm taking like a
utilitarian welfare here so yes so one
can you know think about sort of a more
refined objective here so the objective
I'm considering here is the sum of the
utilities of the individuals in the
society
but the probability of intention it is
there yes the probability is there so
like the probability of infection is
already in this utility
so but you know one can you know weight
these you know probabilities differently
I'm not going to do that so I'm just
going to Simply take the sum of these
utilities
I could in principle put a
proportionality constant in front of one
year two terms the positive from social
activities the negative from the
probability how much do your results
depend on this great so you want to look
at the sort of separate the value from
social interactions and the sort of the
cost of the infection probabilities and
then put different weights on those
right yes uh so the results are going to
be the same it's similar so it's not
exactly the same but it's like a sort of
intuition that we see that you know I
will show you in the next slide is going
to be the same
right right so let's see you know what
is the sort of uh optimal testing policy
here uh I guess I'm running out of so do
I have like four minutes to finish
okay
uh so there are three thresholds such
that you know here is the sort of the
characterization of the optimal uh
testing policy so if you have enough
tests then you know it will be optimal
to test all agents and you know we're
going to end up fully utilizing all the
tests
if you have you know some intermediary
value for for the number of tests then
uh we want to sort of discourage social
activity from low value agents and we
end up under utilizing the testing
capacity
and again you know we get to this other
region in which you know low value
agents are going to be you know inactive
themselves so there I'm going to fully
utilize the testing capacity and you
know if the testing capacity is like
very small in this sort of yellow region
I will end up again under utilizing the
uh sort of testing capacity
so the key sort of
sort of like away from from this result
is the optimal testing policy does not
necessarily use old tests
you know you may as well you know find
it optimal to not use some of the tests
that that you have
um and you know naturally what this
suggests is you know perhaps testing
should be combined with with social
distancing right uh so this this sort of
suggests you know perhaps you know
that's where uh you can gain you know
you put some restriction in terms of the
social distancing and perhaps you can
end up you know using all the tests and
and do better so let's say you know
whether we can uh sort of formalize that
idea within the context of our mode
so how am I going to think about social
distancing here or mandatory social
distancing here so I'm just going to put
an upper bound on the social activity
level of individuals I'm going to have
an upper Bound for the high value agents
and an upper Bound for the low value
agents and the rest of the optimization
is the same you know one can easily show
that you know for any testing capacity
there exists a testing policy with
mandatory social distancing that
achieves the social welfare of the first
Quest so you know this is sort of the
best thing you can hope for and you know
in this policy the social planner is
going to end up using the entire you
know testing capacity so the bottom line
here is you know once you combine social
distancing with uh with testing then you
end up using all the tests and you're
going to do you know much better than
you know the case in which you only use
testing
all right so that's all I I want to talk
about so I'm gonna I'm gonna stop here
and thank you I would be more than happy
to take any questions
thank you very much so Abba has a
question okay thank you that's fantastic
talk I like so by social distancing are
you talking about isolation
self-isolation or maintaining six feet
distance from somebody very good so
that's a good point you know how are we
going to enforce these things so for our
model this is you know something very
simple I'm just going to put a cap on
the social activity level you can take
you know you can uh this is you know how
much you can you know get out of your
house or something like that so I'm just
going to put a cap on your social
activity level so that's no that's not
measure on the distance no no no no no
no it's like it's more like social it's
a more like restrictions I guess you
know it's more like yeah
um yeah
um I really enjoyed that talk thank you
uh so I was just thinking that uh it
might also be interesting to study a
model in which testing decisions are
also endogenous where people are
deciding whether or not to get tested I
don't know if it would make a difference
here but I I think I didn't follow the
discussion before but apparently maybe
your model is going to go through
whether people have social preferences
or not but when when uh the interesting
things might happen if that's actually
fantastic yeah that's a great question I
think this goes back to like the
question Christian asked earlier as well
uh you know if you make that a decision
then you know there may be some
incentives to sort of either lie about
the results of the testing or perhaps
not test because you think that you may
have got an infection you know there may
be things like that as well so I don't
know you know
how that's going to change the model
or the analysis actually yeah I don't
know but yeah I agree with you that that
would be like a very interesting yeah
direction to explore yeah actually it's
very related point so basically if there
is mandatory social distancing then
people wouldn't get tests if the testing
decision is uh whether to be tested or
not is a voluntary decision
right yeah so
um yeah again I don't quite know the
answer but yeah I do agree that's just a
great question so like like
so basically like your your decision is
not only about your you know level of
social activity but also you know how
often you want to get tested I guess
that can be a choice you know
um
how is that going to change the result I
actually don't know so this is it
requires you know I need more time to
think about you know how is that going
to change the result but I agree that
that's a great question so we can we can
discuss that
if you add mandatory social distancing
and so that you increase the optimum or
yes yes so you you get to to the first
phase which is basically you're
maximizing the the welfare without the
equilibrium constraint so as if you know
you don't need any coordination among
people so you know you you kill one of
the constraints so you get to a higher
objective that is right yes that is
exactly correct yes
okay so I suggest that we thank our
speaker again and we can ask further
questions for the break thank you thank
you so much